shooting welcome to science hangout from
science mission I'm science mission
today we have a dr. David Hendricks
assistant professor of biochemistry
biophysics and computer science from
Oregon State University dr. Hendricks
has published several articles in
well-known journals is the review of
several regular reviewer for several
journals and is a member of several
organizations welcome dr. Hendricks hi
thank you for having that so that's
let's move and go through our questions
can you at least talk about yourself
sure so as you said I'm a professor of
biochemistry and biophysics I have a two
third appointment in biochemistry and
biophysics and a one third appointment
in computer science I do computational
biology and I'm interested in
understanding how genes are regulated
and using computers algorithms
statistics and probability to try and
understand gene regulation and in a
broad sense and in a lot of different
systems so if you want to know a little
bit about my background actually started
off in 2000 math my undergraduate
degrees are in physics and math and it
was a little difficult at first for me
to go into biology because this is all
about universal principles and then once
you go in biology and you kind of find
there is no universal principle so
there's almost an exception to every
rule that you learn but over time with
the advent of the you know the
high-throughput sequencing and the
genome revolution I started to become
more interested in biology because
you're able to answer questions at a
genome-wide level you're able to study
um at a genome-wide level and compare
different organisms and it's in its
approach and it's you know biology is
becoming more and more quantitative
everyday and it is in some sense
approaching something similar to this
and that we're learning maybe not
universal principles but at least common
archetypes or motifs regulatory
archetypes that are used over and over
again throughout many different
biological systems and so that's kind of
where I am now and certainly still
interested in math and physics and
always looking for ways of modeling
however I'm studying that's always
difficult I find genomic data is very
difficult to model it's varied in other
words from as a physicist you want to
form simple models and those don't
always extend well to complex systems
like a genome so okay you know you have
being a stencil effects America can you
please uh like talk about other
extracurricular activities you do like
how is your off research do you do
anything else on your hobbies and the
things I have a dog I like to walk my
dog I do you know thing is it's kind of
funny for scientists we like to spend a
lot of our weekend times working on
research and it doesn't mean that we're
don't have any better thing better to do
it just means that we're really
interested in what we do and it's
exciting to go in and try and figure
figure new things out and then I think
it's the whole thing that always drives
me is the promise of new discovery once
you've had a taste of discovery and that
feeling of what it's like to see
something for the first time that's you
know something that really has a high
impact on on a lot of myself and a lot
of other people but other than that I
like to go I like to go on hikes when I
can and I like to do drawings I like to
I'm interested in drawing I dabbled in
drawing some comic strips
like that but lately I've also been
interested in drawing scientific figures
illustrations you know that can help in
papers in manuscripts that I'm writing
but also educational material that I'm
working on that's not just draw for fun
- and I'm yeah I'm a really big star
Wars fan uh-huh um I don't have any Star
Wars trinkets on my desk but I'm a big
star Wars fan and I spend a decent
amount of time enjoying uh Star Wars and
the Star Wars fan community and use like
a other Star Wars seconds so that's good
and can you talk about the other mental
models and uh um
I had a pretty unique background I
started off as his extract students and
my adviser was a physics professor who
recently became a computational genomics
or genomics research researcher
genomicist I guess is what they're
called and at the time in the early 21st
century there were no bioinformatics
graduate degrees there were no in many
cases the whole notion of the
bioinformatics professor bioinformatics
didn't exist nowadays there are
departments there are programs there are
things like that but back then the these
are things being done by physicists and
mathematicians that were starting to go
into biology and a lots changed in the
past 17 or so years but my adviser was a
condensed matter physicist dan rocks are
who became you know went we've got
involved in a huge diversity of subjects
throughout his research career ranging
from evolutionary biology to protein
folding to genome assembly in annotation
and phylogenetics but i learned a lot as
the grad students and I learned
different ways of applying some of the
math that's used in physics to study
genomes I guess you could say and then
um I did a postdoc in a Drosophila
embryo elegy lab for Mike Levine at
Berkeley and so my PhD was at Berkeley
in the niche of postdoc at Berkeley with
Mike Levine and so he's a famous
drosophila embryo gist that has made a
lot of important discoveries in terms of
fundamental biology about gene
regulation um
and that and he's still making
discoveries about fundamental knowledge
of gene regulation and I think when I
was in his lab that was what excited me
is even you know if we're basically at a
time where where the data was growing
and growing and becoming more and more
detailed and you were able to act answer
questions by analyzing genome-wide data
about gene regulation so we found some
new things about gene regulation and
about micro RNAs and how they're
processed and about something called
shadow enhancers we found these
enhancers these sis regulatory elements
or sis regulatory modules if you will
that are in some sense secondary to
another enhancer there's not a real
obvious difference between a primary
enhancer and a shadow enhancer other
than the shadow enhancers typically are
evolving more quickly they have lower
levels of conservation presumably
because they're used less frequently and
in maybe in some cases they're more
distal from the gene that they regulate
anyway we also found another class of
small RNAs called Moore's micro RNA
offset RNAs unit rates until my current
is and we found some other things about
how
RNA polymerase stalling might be
regulated so these are like really
really eight basic questions about how
genes are regulated and then I did a
postdoc for three years at MIT in
Manila's calluses lab and so in that
time period I did some work on small RNA
is to see if small RNAs could be
involved in regulating chromatin but
also some work in non-coding RNA is long
non-coding RNAs and I was exposed to and
begin working on machine learning to a
much larger degree some of the early
stuff I did in DNA motif finding was
machine learning and in every you know
in every sense of the word but I think
when I was at MIT at csail computer
science artificial intelligence
laboratory I was exposed to a lot of um
powerful computational approaches for
machine learning approaches like
logistic regressions or vector machine
random forests things like that and just
ways of evaluating them and ways of
thinking about them and but also exposed
to things like the importance of high
resolution graphics you know things that
I've taken with me you look at the I
always tell my students you look at the
high-impact papers out there one thing
is they they all have in common not only
are they doing really good important
science but they present it in a way
highly professional and highly organized
and highly beautiful and in many cases
they're you know beautiful
high-resolution graphics to represent
your data and to convey your point is
really an important valuable skill and
so those are some of the things that
I've picked up over the years so okay
and let's talk about you a lab like how
big is the lab how do you interact with
your glass student postdocs just talk a
little bit about them I am
in my lab is my office is actually in
the middle of my lab I have windows on
my walls of students inside here be out
so there's pros and cons that the pros
are I'm almost always available the cons
are um maybe I'm wrong to available you
know to it it's hard to get away and
keep some writing on my own so I need to
sometimes you to do that at night or
find some other time to do it but I'm
highly interactive with my students and
I'm a highly engaged with the work
almost to the point of micromanaging
although I try not to micromanage but I
think especially for students that are
new to programming it's important for me
to look at their know so I do look at
note I do look at students code even
when you know especially when they're
new to it but after a certain point I
get I gain confidence and I can sort of
focus on looking at the results rather
than the actual code and so yeah and
then I just try and impart things on my
students that taken me 10 years to learn
I try and tell them at the beginning you
know so they don't take ten years to
learn those things know so okay so weird
things you know we're we're primarily a
dry lab we do computational biology
we're doing a little bit of experiments
actually read ably in some experiments
and but it's mostly a computational lab
working on genomics and some other stuff
that's on the horizon that's not really
genomics but like same thing it's still
kind of interesting so yeah so how do
you know like correlate your genomics
things to biology like you're not a
biology it's a how comfortable and how
have you progressed into the biology
part of it
you know I would actually call myself a
biologist Wow I'm good I feel like over
time I have become a biologist and I am
interested in biological questions my
home department is biochemistry and
biophysics and part of the reason why
that is is because the questions that
really motivate me and interest me are
biological in nature no and I want to
learn new biological principles I don't
just want to I don't just want to find
things that are already known biology I
want to find new biology that's what
really drives and I know a lot of
biology I mean I think I've been doing I
you know when I started off India name
of P finding it was a very abstract um
almost mathematical way of describing
something biological it was a sequence
of AC s GS and T's and I was looking for
a pattern and so in that case it's very
abstract but later on you know you find
out that oh those patterns are actually
binding sites for proteins for
transcription factors and then you learn
oh well maybe these transcription
factors interact with other
transcription factors in those
cooperative bindings that you're looking
for pairs of motifs and so over time you
build up a critical mass of knowledge of
biological knowledge until eventually
you know Here I am seven I've been I've
been doing computational biology now for
like almost 17 years well so I think at
some point I'm a biologist you know I'm
I'm interested in biological questions
I'm thinking about biological questions
I don't always know everything about
biology by any stretch of the
imagination I'm always learning stuff
and it's important to always be a
student you know I am still a student
I'm I'm a student of biology and I'm a
student of machine learning and there's
things that I'm still learning but you
know you just take it one day at a time
and and so I don't know if that answers
your question but yes absolutely
in biology yeah okay can you share your
work with us please sure so go to the
talk yeah so today I'm going to talk
about um let's see share this so we're
good on a screen looks good yep
I don't mind turning this off but either
way you want to do this just try this
how's that yeah but yeah it looks good
as long as you can move it off yeah I
think I can so basically I'm going to
talk about biological discovery through
transcriptomics and like I mentioned
before I think biological discovery is
something that interests me let's let me
just keep to my capitalization here cuz
I should do that biological discovery
the idea that we can find new things we
can find new biology this is what
interests me and so I'm going to talk
about the technique of transcriptomics
and it's something that's kind of in
many ways revolutionized biology in the
past years
okay so complete um it's not okay let me
just uh yeah I guess I'd you have to
turn this on okay so broadly speaking
this is a little schematic little
illustration that I drew you to shed
some light on what transcriptome
assembly is and what your district omics
is essentially you start off with a
collection of isoforms in the genome
that are transcribed into spliced
transcripts so they're spliced with the
introns removed and eukaryotic systems
these are typically fragmented into RNA
fragments and then a cDNA library is
built from these RNA fragments and you
may consider mapping them back to the
genome some of the reads will have gap
those re in the reeds in the alignment
essentially corresponding to the
original intron introns and the clusters
of reeds the overlap can correspond to
exons and so once the reeks of map to
the genome in the case of reference
guide a transcriptome assembly you can
build a graph representation for example
where the the nodes are the exons and
the edges are the introns and that can
ultimately build into a transcript model
which ideally should recapitulate the
original isoforms that you were trying
to understand and you know this is
what's known as deep sequencing so this
is essentially the only equation that
I'm going to show well I'll probably
show a couple other ones but just this
is this notion of deep sequencing here
this expression the depth of the
sequencing is essentially the number of
reads times the length of the reads on
average divided by in this case the size
of the transcriptome the total length of
the transcriptome that we're trying to
study and so in essence this describes
the average number of reads that map to
a particular exon in the genome on
average and so one of the things that's
really amazed me is the fact that now in
2017 or is this is from 2015 that the
number of long non-coding RNA is
actually outnumbers protein coding
transcripts or mrna s and in fact to a
large degree if you look here the linked
rnas are actually 3 times the amount of
protein coding genes so when I was a
grad student you know you pretty much
think of these as the genes but they're
not the genes are much broader set
including things that do not encode a
protein if you include these transcripts
of unknown coding potential and
pseudogenes and read through
transcription it's essentially like 3/4
is non-coding so I'm going to talk to
you about three different stories the
first is looking at linked rnase long
intergenic non-coding rnas that respond
to a biotic stress and poplar abiotic
stress as we see is cold
droughts things like that salt and then
I'm going to talk to about age onset
rhythmic gene expression in Drosophila
and then if I have time I'm going to
talk to you about detecting cancer with
stack denoising auto-encoders how much
time do we have left like another half
an hour or so err okay so yeah we may
not have time to get to everything but
I'll do my best so so first to give an
illustration of essentially this
pipeline described here um
this is essentially what we did we took
our facts T files we quality filtered
with skewer we aligned the genome with
hai sat form bam files and Sam tools and
essentially assemble the transcriptome
with string time and then what we can do
is essentially we did a multi-step
process to filter out things that any
signature being protein counting or
essentially not being non-coding first
we filtered out transcripts less than
200 that's kind of a different filter
that's just the definition of long
intragenic non-coding rnas of the
greater than 200 nucleotides we filter
out anything with a significant coding
potential from this program called C Pat
coding potential assessment tool
we ran other tools trans decoder to
filter out protein coding potential
blasted to a rabid OPS's and essentially
scan for PCM domains and land it on
about 2400 long non-coding RNAs and then
we basically filtered out those that had
that had low expression we call those
significantly impressed essentially
their median is greater than or equal to
0.1 in all tissues and that reduces down
to 930 then finally we said how many of
these are significantly differentially
expressed meaning there's at least one
case you relative to control where these
things are significantly differentially
expressed the result was about a hundred
link was exactly a hundred link RNAs
with 14 of them partially overlapping
transposons so we kind of filtered those
out as just transpose on overlapping
transcripts okay so one of the things we
may be interested in is looking at
significant differential expression so
this is showing significantly
differentially expressed link RNAs so
each column is a given link RNA that we
identified the rows are the different
stress conditions that we evaluated and
different tissues will be evaluated and
so you see we did three tissues leaf
root and xylem and those the stresses
involved were cold drought heat and salt
in addition to control and then each of
those stresses were for prolonged and
short term stress treatments okay and
then essentially to skip a rough sketch
we found the majority of these long
non-coding rnas were being expressed
under long term salt stress for whatever
reason in leaves long term drought
stress was also enriched for long
non-coding RNAs in the root of these
plants and so just to reiterate this is
populist trick at carve up poplar this
is a common tree used in for example
that they grow fast they're used they're
interested people are interested in
poplar as a potential fuel source for
example so you look sick ethanol so you
can grow a lot of biomass pretty rapidly
and so you know we're interested in what
these things are regulated and so one
essentially characterized these long
non-coding RNAs that respond to abiotic
stress and the other thing that we found
was a lot of tissue specific long
non-coding RNA if you want MIT I could
probably do that but basically um Wow so
here's one little bit of biology this
eye is kind of like a weird thing lncRNA
long non-coding RNA but sometimes you
see an eye there and really that means
intergenic essentially meaning that it
does not overlap a protein coding
but if you want to be more general just
this link RNA without the eye is the
most general class so let's stick to
that so we were able to identify a
number of tissue specific link RNAs in
our set and so this is essentially
showing the leaf root and xylem specific
link RNAs and their expression and in
this case we're showing the expression
the relative to the minimum tissue and
we found 151 tissue specific link RNAs
okay so one of the first things we
wanted to do was essentially say are
these long non-coding rnas we don't
really know what they're doing we just
know there's own transcript right it's
not encoded protein so first thing we
can do is say are there any significant
correlations with other protein coding
transcripts in this case here this is
showing a particular long non-coding RNA
forgive the names they're all using
these T cons names we're just
automatically generated by the software
and this particular one happens to be
significantly correlated with this
protein coding transcript X also
transferase excellent so um you know
that's kind of interesting I guess but
so then the other thing you could do is
say well what if we look at all mRNAs
they're annotated to a specific pathway
and so that particular example hexose
will transference happens to be part of
this island biosynthesis pathway here so
in this case and this figure we're
showing for each pathway annotated in
plant react tome all the significant
correlations between linked rnas and
protein coding transcripts that are a
member of that pathway so in doing so we
can associate linked RNAs with pathways
based on if they are correlated with
more mRNAs than you would expect due to
chance
and so we can build this kind of a heat
map here or what this means is you can
zoom in here like each of these little
squares corresponds to a significant
number of correlated protein coding
transcripts and so in this case this
particular t columns it happens to be
correlated with GDP elf yukos
biosynthesis that's the pathway
indicated here and this particular link
RNA here this one four two one nine
right here happens to be significantly
correlated with aux-in signaling which
is one of these plant signaling pathways
a sort of a plant hormone ok so then
when all is said and done we basically
have a pathway association for these
long non-coding RNAs we can't say
precisely with the long non-coding RNA
is doing we can only say there's a
decent chance it will be involved in
that pathway ok so the next thing we can
do is say are there any stretched
conditions that are associated with a
pathway and in this case again leaf salt
being the most linked RNAs we see here
this particular dark band it's linked to
carotenoid biosynthesis and the TCA
cycle which maybe I'll get to a little
bit later um these are kind of connected
pathways in many senses there's a lot of
genes that are sort of common amongst
them if you go back to this clustering
you can see this this cluster here all
of these you see carotenoid biosynthesis
Calvin cycle ox and signaling and TCA
cycle is right here but in many ways
these linked RNAs are significantly
correlated with a lot of genes linked to
these pathways ok so this is a couple of
examples of some interesting ones
this particular linked RNA right here
- Jason - this protein coding gene it is
significantly up regulated under
prolonged salt condition relative to
control you can see control very little
expression
it's upregulated and salt and it
actually contains a protein coding
transcript in its intron so here's
another one basically this this one is
interesting because it was a really long
intron like 40 KB for zero kilobases in
length but it's significantly down
regulated in leaf drought so it's
expressed under control conditions and
leaves and it's essentially silenced
under drought and we have validated that
this splice Junction is really being
used and by designing splice Junction
specific primers okay so anyway the
takeaway here is we can use
transcriptomics to not only identify
lots of new genes that are non-coding
but also potentially with enough
different conditions we can correlate
them with protein coding genes and then
ultimately associate them with pathways
biological pathways that they may be
involved in and we're essentially
forming hypotheses as to what these
things could be doing that hopefully can
be carried out later on so I next want
to move on to a story in Drosophila
melanogaster which is you know a common
model system for studying biology
because it is a simple organism that we
know a lot about so one of the things
the interested in studying is the
circadian clock okay so what is the
circadian clock it is a biological
negative feedback loop or a set of genes
that are involved in a negative feedback
loop where you have per period and
timeless they're forming these protein
dimers that in turn repress clock and
cycle heterodimers and clock in cycle
are sort of like the positive arm of the
clock they're transcription factors that
will in turn activate lots of genes life
period and timeless and like some other
genes that also support the cycle and if
you're post-translationally
by period and timeless light comes in so
light is obviously a big factor in
circadian rhythms we're exposed to light
12 hours out of the day light directly
essentially activates this other protein
called cryptochrome which in turn when
light activated will repress timeless
okay that's the circadian clock why is
this important
so um a lot of times people are more and
more staying up you know looking at
their phones looking at Facebook exposed
to more direct light um and not only
that aging is a big factor here as
people get older they have less restful
sleep and they have sleep that is more
punctuated by bouts of of wakefulness so
what we wanted to do is we wanted to
compare the expression of young flies to
old flies and so this figure here clock
is that one transcription factor and you
can see it has this nice rhythmic
pattern after 24 hours it decreases the
expression then comes back up and
there's no significant difference
between young and old okay it's
essentially the same profile when we
looked at period to our surprise
remember period is the negative arm of
the clock it is actually increasing in
amplitude at the MRNA level in old
compared to young so the expectation is
with more period we might expect more
repression of the clock turns out that
doesn't actually happen that way because
the protein levels of period are
actually decreased I won't really talk
about that but it was interesting that
previous papers had actually shown that
period was decreasing with age and the
reason is is because they were using
this actin gene as their qPCR control
which is actually decreasing with age so
we found a new gene DCP 2 that's
relatively constant expression in young
and old
so confirming that period is in fact
increasing at the mr
level with age so we found all these
other weird examples that phase shift
with age some of these genes actually
have a complete shift 12-hour shift in
terms of the time that their Pete as the
Flies get older so we're able to
generate figures like this that are heat
maps each row of this heat map is a gene
though each column is the expression
level at a particular time point so you
can see there's two clear rhythm going
on here of high low high low high low
but on the right hand side it looks like
a low resolution version of the
left-hand side um it is kind of
stochastic these are genes that are
rhythmic only in young but to our
surprise we found a similar class of
genes that are rhythmic only in old
flies they're stochastic or lowly
expressed in young but then they become
rhythmic and old so here's a snapshot of
some of these genes that were validated
by qPCR and we actually continued this
today seventy-five old flies which is
kind of like the peak age of the fly of
a fruit fly and then essentially a lot
of these genes actually continue to
increase in expression as the flies get
older we developed a two-dimensional
representation we call the differential
rhythmicity score that incorporates the
degree to which the periodicity changes
and the degree to which the amplitude
changes and so we can plot on a 2d axis
here some of these genes like imple 3
which is lactate dehydrogenase it's kind
of like the quintessential example it's
higher in amplitude and more rhythmic
other examples like h SP 22 are
significantly higher in amplitude and
old but not that much in per breath
Missa tee it's actually it is 422 is
slightly rhythmic and young flies but
it's just so Lily expressed that it
doesn't really look rhythmic but we were
able to find these different classes and
were able to identify what we call LLC
late-life cyclers based on this
statistical score and we were able to
confirm through
qpcr that the LLC's increased with age
and then the other thing that we found
is the LLC's are activated in young
flies by oxidative stress oxidative
stress like reactive oxygen species
things like hydrogen peroxide that are
highly reactive and are one of the key
stresses that we encounter during aging
oxidative where we're exposed to more
reactive oxygen as we get older and so
therefore these genes for whatever
reason are activated by oxidative stress
in young flies and their expression in
oxidatively stressed young flies
essentially phenol copies the expression
in old flies not only that we next
showed that clock the positive arm of
the hidden clock is necessary for these
genes to exhibit their LLC behavior the
exception being BNL here which is
actually better in wild-type um no
excuse me um the exception being I guess
HSB 22 here which is actually increased
insight means BNL looks like a true
circadian gene because its highest in
wild-type and then decreases to
essentially low levels when you take out
clock insight some of these other genes
are doing a little bit weird stuff but
some of them as you can see this age of
22 and maybe this one are still rhythmic
in the even in the absence of sight so
the other key result here is that these
late alive cyclers require light they
require exposure to light if you put
them in constant darkness they go away
and that is in some case suggests it is
not circadian it is not strictly linked
to the circadian clock which is
which does persist in constant darkness
once you take away the lights okay so I
also one of the things that we found was
um going back to this idea of non-coding
RNAs we found this group of non-coding
RNAs Knobble non-coding rnas and who
would have thought in 2017 that there
would still be novel genes in Drosophila
yet to be found but we found these genes
that are rhythmic and old and not
rhythmic and young and on further
evaluation we have this one gene called
crescendo that when we did qpcr we were
able to uniquely define Q PCR primers
it's reasonably well conserved and it's
only expressed in old flies that's why
we were able to find it because nobody
looks in old flies they only look in
young flies for new genes this gene
keeps getting higher and higher with age
until day 75 it's sort of like looks and
exponentially more highly expressed with
age essentially in other words the day
75 expression trajectory the worse the
expression and a 55 so when we looked to
see what these non-coding rnas could be
doing we found that they that they all
essentially overlap annotations for what
are called mature or PI Rene's PI Rene's
are the largest class of endogenous
small rnas in animals and PI Rene's our
genomes natural defense against
transposons for example transposons are
these so-called jumping genes that copy
themselves and reinsert themselves
throughout the genome RNAs are thought
to combat transposon activity they
degrade treads bosons so there is
evidence now that transposons are
actually active in aging fly brains and
it's not hard to imagine why they would
be really harm
for for for our aging system major if
you're inserting transposons over the
place it's going to wreak all sorts of
havoc disrupting protein-coding genes
disrupting regulatory DNA so we believe
these PI renée's are becoming acted only
in in old flies specifically to combat
aged onset stresses due to transposon
entity so that basically concludes my
section on the LLC's late-life cyclers
and the takeaway message there is that
the late-life cyclers to a large degree
we think they could be part of a stress
response pathway that's activated late
in life so how are we doing on time now
you still have about 8-10 minutes okay I
could briefly touch on steep learning
stuff and everything that I've talked
about so far is kind of looking at
statistically significant genes in terms
of what's the most highly expressed um
but we wanted to know can we move away
from that can we use machine learning to
move away from that and one of the
questions that we had was um can we
detect cancer can you tell that a given
cell is cancerous versus non cancerous
based on its gene expression okay and we
wanted to use deep learning the reason
why we want to use deep learning versus
ordinary machine learning is there's
more layers which kind of gives more
detail you don't have to do feature
engineering in these layers it's sort of
encodes its own features meaning it
learns what's important in the data
rather than you telling it what specific
quantities it should be used in the
machine learning so it's capable of
learning features in is capable of
learning non-linearity in the data so
this is a picture of a Google's deep
dream it's kind of unsettling
this is basically what they did is they
took convolutional neural network
trained it to recognize dogs and then
they basically mutated the image taking
mutations that improve the
classification for being a dog and it
produces these weird effects that it's
important to remember with deep learning
we want to be careful with what we're
doing because sometimes the computer can
go a little haywire and think this is a
dog no person would say that's a dog um
so we want to be careful with how how we
interpret the results from from eath
learning um be used what's called
stacked denoising auto-encoders so one
of the challenges for studying gene
expression especially cancer is you're
dealing with this dimensionality curse
here you have a high number of features
which are your genes 20,000 40,000 genes
and a limited number of samples
typically on the order of a thousand and
in this in this day and age and so we
need to either get more data get more
patients to give samples or what we can
do is what we did and that is to do
dimensionality reduction and to reduce
the dimension of the gene expression
data so that it's on par with the number
of samples that we have and so this is
what's called an autoencoder it's a
basic dimensionality reduction it
basically encodes the data to a reduced
dimensional representation in such a way
that it can reconstruct the original
data that's true to the original data
it's accurately reconstructing the
original data from its reduced
dimensional representation and
mathematically it's basically a linear
or affine transformation with the data
times a matrix plus a vector and then
applying this nonlinear sigmoid function
or non-linear squashing function and you
can do in addition to just doing one
layer of an autoencoder you can do a
stacked autoencoder where you actually
iteratively
reduce the dimensionality of the data
and by doing it iteratively in the sort
of stepwise fashion
you actually lose less information than
if you did it all in one jump then we
cannot do other strategies to avoid
overfitting one of them is called
denoising we're actually uh essentially
adding noise to the data here
stochastically modifying our data and
then also dropout where we stochastic
lis remove various nodes in our layers
to sort of train more robustness into
the model and so when you put it all
together you get a stacked denoising
auto-encoder and so we took the gene
expression data from cancer patients and
healthy patients reduce the
dimensionality into this new feature
space in such a way that we could
reconstruct the original data and then
we can use this new feature space to do
machine learning and basically in this
case we're looking at ovarian and
prostate cancer and I'll skip over that
but we compared it to some of these
other machine learning approaches single
layer artificial neural networks and
restricted Boltzmann machines and deep
belief Network where some other
approaches that we compared our model to
so in the case of classification what
we're essentially doing is we're
learning this reduced dimensional
representation and then we're taking
that data and feeding it into these
traditional machine learning approaches
like a single layer artificial neural
network Boltzmann machine and belief
Network and our actor and see we get
about 92% accuracy here for the ovarian
cancer using the neural network and
about ninety one point two nine percent
accuracy for prostate cancer when we use
this traditional single layered neural
network on our reduced dimensional data
so had we done this on the unreduced
data it would be worse and we'd be
dealing with that dimensionality curse
we wouldn't have enough data to train
the parameters that we need so we had
this idea we have this reduced we have
this iterative mapping here these
matrices that are reducing here what if
we take the product of all of our
matrices
and so this is some something some sense
linearizing a nonlinear transformation
but what happened was we did this we got
this like nice Gaussian fit of these
products so we take the product of all
these matrices and then ask what genes
have the highest weights and this
product matrix by fitting this to a
Gaussian finalist statistically
significant weights appear and we
selected a subset of genes that had
statistically significant contribution
to the dimensionality reduction of the
gene expression data and when we train
on this it's a new data these highly
interactive genes we actually got a much
smoother convergence during machine
learning with the restricted Boltzmann
machine than we did with the full set of
stacked denoising auto-encoder features
and when we applied our machine learning
approaches to our is deeply connected
genes in the case of ovarian cancer we
actually got better accuracy so we
essentially use machine learning to
identify a subset of genes that are not
necessarily the most highly expressed so
typical approaches would to say what's
highly differentially expressed we're
able to find the most meaningful genes
based on the degree to which that they
contribute to a dimensionality reduction
of the cancer gene expression we had
similar results for the prostate cancer
and when all is said and done we find a
lot of genes that are enriched in that
set and a lot of these genes as you
might expect are related to go terms
that are might be associated with cancer
things like cell death apoptosis so
we're able to find these genes that are
seem to be relevant and something that
we're going to pursue a little further
and figure out what these genes are
doing and I would like to acknowledge
the students and other people that did
the work and the poplar project this was
a collaboration with the J swallow
here at Oregon State supported by
funding from the Department of Energy
and that was the work of my stage in
Michelle Wiley and the circadian rhythms
and aging project was the work of a
former student Rachel pencil in
collaboration with the Google to vich
lab and Eileen is this is a research
scientist on that team and then finally
for the speck Tina losing autoencoder
that was done by MIDI sadani a and Reza
Danny and so with that I will conclude
the presentation and thank you
can you unshare the presentation please
sure let's see how about that no let me
say yeah that's good yeah I have just
couple of because of the time thing I
had a couple of questions one is
regarding the lung coding RNA
sure there is a disproportionate amount
of RNA compared to these RN is compared
to the proteins and all so I we know
that there is lot of regulation at the
non-coding region happening at all so
like so many rnas play role somehow in
regulating so many genes or is it just
like some are redundant how do you those
kind of RNAs out there I think it's
still a work in progress I think we're
starting to still learning what they
would they do I mean if you take a look
at smaller names like micro rna's a
given protein coding transcript to be
regulated by dozens of distinct micro
rna's so it's possible that a similar
number similarly large number of long
non-coding rnas can be involved in
regulating a given gene but at the same
time linked rnase do other things other
than just regulating protein coding
genes they play structural roles in
molecular complexes
I mean a good example is telomerase
there's an RNA called Terk the tama
plumber's RNA component and it is an
interesting long non-coding RNA and
there are actually disease associated
allelic variants in that transcript so
in other words there are mutations
genetic mutations that are associated
with diseases and they're not in a
protein coding gene but only in that
long non-coding RNA presumably mutations
that affected structure for example
possible so not to mention classic exam
the classic the classical non-coding RNA
is like the ribosomal RNAs these are
things that we've known about for
decades and they place important
structural roles of the ribosome so I
think really we're all we've only begun
to understand what long coding RNAs are
doing they're scaffolds for molecular
complexes they're regulating genes
they're recruiting genes I think there's
a good chance that they operate through
sequence specific patterns sequence
specific activity much like micro RNAs
do and who knows what they do maybe
we'll we'll have something maybe it
turns out a lot of them are doing
something we haven't even conceived of
yet for all we know so okay and the last
one is I actually sit sorry to interrupt
but it does you and it's okay
early on why non-coding RNAs but that's
what makes them exciting and I think a
lot of what I've talked about is genes
while in coding RNAs and why they're
regulated but I think the really
interesting question is how they
regulate what are the molecular decadent
these things are using to regulate other
genes and to do what they do and I think
that's only understood for just a a
dozen while including RNAs maybe if that
so
okay and lastly the jeans which through
the machine learning like you have the
cell that pathway and all those things
there bunch of genes are associated with
the this pathway or like cells that
mechanism so how do you but putting them
together like I mean like there is a
known pathway a few known pathways in
different organisms different cell it's
things now you are talking about another
hundred of them you are bunching them
together so do they play some role like
outside like minor role outside or like
they do have a major role on specific
things specific cell death pathway what
is your like I mean like it is still too
early again as you said for non-coding
RNA I think I think about currently I
think the takeaway there is that maybe
we shouldn't just you know a lot of
previous studies of just say well what's
the most highly expressed in cancer well
no maybe that's not always the most
meaningful maybe there are genes that
are more subtly expressed but are still
playing more critical regulatory roles
and the hope is that maybe by doing this
some of this machine learning we can
identify those those more subtle
examples what would we do with them in
the short term perhaps they can be used
as biomarkers in in a cancer diagnosis
you know if you have a tissue sample and
you could just if you knew those genes
you could simply test the expression of
those genes with that said that's also
tricky because if they're more subtly
expressed it's harder to know it's
harder to use them as biomarkers because
there may be their change in expression
it's not that drastic um but hope is
that maybe this will enable us to but
focus our attention on these new genes
are these genes are not new genes and in
some cases they're not necessarily newly
implicated in cancer but maybe this will
serve as a
way to change our focus and to look at
studying what these genes can be doing
but it's clear that they're relevant to
cancer expression cancer gene expression
so I think with that I think we'll
conclude this hangout thank you so much
for taking time it's pretty interesting
in fact I learned a lot from whatever
you are presented this is it like I want
worked so much on all this stuff but
certainly it is a very new field even
though it's been done for a little bit a
few several years but I think things are
opening up right now and I think we hope
to see more of your work more of your
publications in the near future thank
you so much okay thank you for inviting